all right let's hear from some more
people you can get in touch with me
through our discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to aaron from los
angeles california erin you're on the
air
hello david um i've just had um i guess
like some questions regarding um
i uh fcc standards and everything like
do you think that uh media companies do
you think the fcc should bring back the
fairness doctrine that they had back in
the 80s in order to make i guess
representation of diverse ideas
on all uh networks uh more palpable and
uh secondly like
just as someone that has uh a little bit
of experience and like i guess community
radio like i'm very very skeptical of
adding new regulations on like anything
new sec regulations in particular yeah i
think the cat is out of the bag on this
i do not think bringing because the
media landscape has changed so much i've
said before i don't think bringing back
the fairness doctrine is really going to
achieve
what maybe we hope it would achieve um
so much now of media consumption is
internet based in all ways even people
in cars cars now have hot spots and i do
not think that in a way that is subject
to fcc jurisdiction you're really going
to be able to
accomplish
what one imagines you might be able to
accomplish with it so i think we need to
be fighting this in other ways and um we
you know we've talked before about what
those ways are but i would not waste i i
believe it's a waste of energy to focus
on an fcc based fairness doctrine to
sort of like fix the problems in media
right now
i i agree and i also just think that
like a lot of the uh just outright
regulations that uh have that the fcc
has just more harms independent creators
and like independent like outlets and
university outlets as opposed to you
know the major conservative political
talk networks that have been getting
away through loopholes for decades
yes there's no doubt about that and i
think that this is really going to come
from you know and for i hate to say this
because it's like
sometimes it feels like if you just put
in some law you fix everything when the
real solution is more complicated
the media problem is heavily based on
such a total lack of media literacy in
the country where if we had
better uh education around media
literacy
we would not even need to be thinking
about a lot of these other solutions
that are much more
legally based and it's a long-term
solution i know you can't fix that
overnight but i continue to believe
that's where the solution lies
it's just so puzzling to me how that's
just such a major thing how media
literacy is just
not prevalent especially because in
american education systems they
prioritize so much about reading and
writing yes at a young age from
kindergarten but it's not translating
over our english education isn't
teaching us these types of skills at all
and
there are countries that start teaching
reading and writing later than the us
the everybody still ends up at the same
level but their media literacy ends up
ahead and i believe part of it is
this is just an opinion based on some
things i've read
at ages four five six instead of jumping
in prematurely into reading and writing
there's more about thinking
and i think it is something that just
should be thought about is all i'm
saying
okay
that's fair yeah well thank you david
all right aaron from los angeles thanks
very much i do appreciate that great to
hear from you
let's go
next to um where do we want to go next i
mean there's just there's just so many
people
that that want to talk
how about um how about colin from iowa
colin you're next
hello david can you hear me yes i can
well this is this is really an honor
david sir i've been uh such a fan of the
show the honor is my um
my my main choice for uh
any news that i do
beautiful um
who well this actually happened i'm
sorry i'm a little starstruck you're
doing great you're doing great did you
have a question today
i do have a question okay so
it's a little bit on the lighter side
i'd say i mean obviously i would talk
about covet or whatever but
this is just something that i've heard
recently among like a lot of liberals or
whatever it's about
okay well i'm from iowa obviously and
marijuana is illegal there
so i was like thinking
i think i said something along the lines
of like
what if biden were to like the present
blind were to like decriminalize
marijuana if it's decriminalized in a
lot of states and from what i've heard a
lot of the decriminalized states because
i also live in illinois like illinois is
my second home i guess you can say
and like it's it's uh
it's legal here and there really hasn't
been a problem there so
what do you think about like the
decriminalization of marijuana
nationally and if joe biden were to do
that how do you think that would affect
his popularity i think his popularity
would increase significantly if he were
to decriminalize i think there's a lot
of people who would prefer that joe
biden
federally legalize marijuana i think
there are different opinions as to
whether he could do that but aside from
that it's it's just not going to be the
next step i think the next step the
logical next step in the progression
would be
decriminalization i think it would be
incredibly popular overall if he did it
there would be people that are mad for
sure
but when you're talking about
decriminalizing you're not saying legal
recreational pot shops on every corner
the way right wingers love to fearmonger
about so they wouldn't be able to do
that they might say it's the first step
towards that but i think it would be
popular i would love for him to do it
and i i'm 100 in favor of that
yeah i totally agree david and for for
one thing for living in iowa like i'll
reveal a little bit about myself i live
in the quad cities so i'm on the iowa
side of the quad cities and i don't know
anybody personally that likes smokes but
from what i've heard a lot a lot of like
the people on my campus they will like
drive over just a few miles just to get
to like rock island to more lean and
then they'd get the pot and then they'd
bring it back to davenport it i think
that is just kind of ridiculous so now i
just want to make sure i understand
because some people may not be familiar
with all of those you're saying they
drive over into illinois to buy the
legal pot
yes the quad cities there's an iowa side
in the illinois side got it got it got
it since since the illinois side is the
legal side you just drive over and then
pick it up right which
yeah that's that's just a quad city
secret for you got it all right well the
secret is now out uh very very much
appreciate the call and yes certainly uh
oh sorry
a little quick on the trigger finger
there uh very much appreciate the call i
am in favor of decriminalization and
legalization i think i i am for both i
am for both
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chili sleep which
makes customizable climate controlled
sleep solutions to sleep better their
flagship products are the uhler sleep
system and the cube sleep system which
is what i have both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chilly blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chilly sleep has a special offer just
for my audience go to chillysleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below